je la ressemblance est frappante alors
une fois pour toute et avait envie de
mettre les choses au point
c'était il ya quelques années il est
allé plus loin depuis là c'était au
stade artisanal et ça m'amusait assez
parce que j'avais connu mme thiery quand
il avait 20 ans il ya dix ans de ça je
ne sais pas quel âge il a mais enfin il
ya 20 ans il ya dix ans et la paix 20
ans peut-être quelques bon alors là
c'était de dans une boîte justement
d'homosexuels ça nous amusait beaucoup
on était entouré d'amis auriez beaucoup
il n'y avait pas que tu es homosexuel
c'était une boîte très parisienne bon
c'était au stade artisanal et tout ce
qui est vous qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire ou bon il prenez une app qui
se mettait sur sa tête bon mais mais
mais il ya toujours le côté mais je les
laissais un peu trop trop de temps à
mettre des serviettes sur la tête et
c'est devenu industriel est alors quand
ça devient industrielle il faut il faut
mettre les choses au point je ne suis
plus du tout du tout du tout d'accord et
je le dis publiquement comme ça tout le
monde est au courant
je ne suis pas fâché je n'ai pas fait de
procès mais les derniers temps il a un
peu dépassé la mesure
et quand on dépasse la mesure je dis
halte parce que mon métier je le fais
avec énormément d'ardeur on dit même
avec du courage sur le mall pas
tellement parce que le courage pourquoi
c'est un métier que j'ai choisi que
j'aime
non mais enfin le métier je le fais et
quand je fais ma publicité c'est moi qui
fais la publicité on me paye pour ça je
n'aime pas du tout du tout qu'on se
serve de moi pour pour leur travail pour
leur boulot
or je prends je pense que thierry s'est
beaucoup servi de moi nous nous sommes
entendus dernièrement on a fait un
arrangement
parce que je lui ai dit c'est attention
si tu continues
ça va dépasser la mesure et moi à ce
moment-là je prendrai
les devants et moi aussi je ne me
mettrais pas car tu as du talent dans
les imitations
mais moi j'ai aussi du talent dans ma
façon de dire je dirais aussi certaines
choses et peut-être que ce n'est pas
bien alors on est sûr vous êtes en
découdre sur l'attenté je jouais chirol
ça vous agace eagles savoir pour quelle
raison ça m'agace pourquoi parce qu'il
est facile il est trop facile de faire
de fer sont enfin entre guillemets
talent parce que bon kirill de lure on a
peut-être mais de se servir du talent
des autres pour pour ce faire sa
carrière et son et son fric soit avec
leur avec le talent de sa prise par
exemple bon c'est ce dont il a le plus
abuser mais il n'est pas le seul
il est de bon ton dans les émissions de
balancer une petite une petite blague à
propos de la liste après ça fait rire
c'est amusant moi je ne comprends pas
c'est ça me dépasse
l'ademe rémy en revanche cela
franchement me vexe et je suis
profondément ennuyé pour finalement on
peut dire des choses certainement mais
dire des choses gentiment et non pas des
choses l'ex à thouars finalement et
madame ça plutôt frêle est extrêmement
gentil de ne pas intenter un procès pour
certaines choses mais ça m'a
profondément choqué franchement et les
vj je le dis publiquement je ne suis
absolument pas complices il le fait
malgré tout mais comme que malgré tout
et malgré moi je tiens à le dire
publiquement fabrègues vous connaissez
bien vous vous rencontrer au plus tôt on
avait mis d'accord non il n'ya pas
d'amitié non c'est un copain c'est pas
un ami mais si où je fais un procès où
je de on en
on devient des ennemis et ce n'est pas
c'est pas la peine non plus mais je le
dis je le proclame
je ne suis pas d'accord pour la saison
prochaine il va faire le gymnase et il
m'a promis qu'ils ne mettraient pas dans
son numéro
je dis ça ne s'était pas vous connaissez
si c'est agaçant quand il
il me décrit qu'il khilal que j'ai la
peau tellement arraché qu'il en fait des
sacs du soir il se fait que pour une
femme de mon âge je le suis pas
arash comme il dit vous pouvez regarder
bon j'ai assez de rides pour ça quand il
dit que quand je jouais super dupont il
disait elle est très aimé des souffles
des ouvreuses parce que à l'entracte
elles peuvent aller se reposer des trucs
comme ça qu'est là qu'il a arrangé à sa
façon je dis non non non non a lyon
patrice cambraye ccva limitation des
gens pour faire des mobilités puisque
nous en sommes aux fins de mise au point
il ya eu trop de points que vous désirez
faire m'avait dit tout à l'heure
sa demande de démission je suis une
actrice très populaire
des gens me téléphone et désire me voir
en dehors de mon métier et ça vous
n'acceptez pas vous ne voulez pas vous
ne voulez vous lit non mais vous aller
vous allez faire de la peine à beaucoup
de gens non parce que j'ai une phrase
qui n'est pas de moi qui n'ai pas de
cocteau non plus parce que on croit que
c'est de cocteau c'est pas vrai c'est du
poète reverdit il n'y a pas d'amour il
ya des preuves d'amour
je voudrais que l'appel que le public
fait à mon égard soit aussi un appel à
double à double sens vous comprenez
c'est peu moi je ne peux pas disposer de
mon temps pour recevoir des personnes
très gentil mais pour le bavardage ou
pour je ne peux pas disposer de mon
temps or la plupart du temps les gens
des gens me disent ce n'est donc dîner
des gens que je ne connais pas devenez
donc signer ou est ce qu'on peut vous
inviter à prendre le thé etc
alors là ça n'est pas la raison du cycle
donc parce que la rançon du succès ce
n'est pas possible parce que je fais un
métier public je voudrais quand même
dans ce que je fais comprenez vous même
dans votre livre il ya une douzaine
d'années vous disiez avoir vu jean paul
sartre simone de beauvoir vue sacha
guitry l'avoir rencontré et on est déçu
mais vous dites j'ai plus appris à les
regards décalés connaître après tout ce
qu'il pense il l'écrit pour 20 francs
l'époque on en sait bien davantage sur
les écrivains au service qu'en perdant
son temps les connaître si gentil d'être
venus d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais c'est
grave ce que vous dites quand même non
pourquoi
une fois quoi il vaut mieux connaître se
refuser quand même à son public mais
mais mais mais mais public là qu'est ce
que je fais j'avais je parle à mon
public
le public est en face de moi y'a 3
millions 4 millions je ne sais pas
quatre millions de personnes je
m'adresse à eux pour m'expliquer pour
expliquer qui je suis et mai mais est ce
que est ce bien utile quand on public
sache comment je fais ma salade alors de
réaction madame